first and foremost let's talk about this
rally that's going on tonight
tell me a little bit about uh your role
uh
in the rally this evening there's a
rally so that we can gather latinas from
across
our city here in las vegas nevada
because we need to stand up to trump we
know that trump has continuously
dehumanized our community
and it's been through rhetoric and it's
been through policy
and so this evening at the rally i'll be
speaking about some of the things that
he's done in our community
and how we can stand up to him in this
election and i was speaking
uh with me familiavota earlier and they
were also saying you know they're really
pushing for
um mail-in ballots due to you know the
pandemic and
also it's a bit more accessible for some
people um who are working
during this time and so i'm wondering if
you could just elaborate that
on that a bit about uh some of those
different options for voting and why
it's important for the latina community
do you want me to talk specifically
about mail or the three different ways
that we can vote
um i guess for this one maybe mail-in
ballots because that's what uh mi
familia voter was focusing on earlier
this election is very different than
most of the elections that we've had
in our life and one of the main reasons
why is it so much safer
for us to just vote at home we're very
fortunate that the nevada state
legislature
supported legislation that allowed for
every eligible voter in the student
nevada
receive a mail invalid and so i really
encourage our community to get out and
vote
and to do that from the comfort of your
home you can fill out your ballot
and then you can either drop it off at a
drop-off location or you can just send
it in the mail
also i was looking at some research
online from pew research center and it
was saying
they were projecting 32 million latinos
who
are eligible to vote this election
season the latino vote is going to
outweigh the black vote for the first
time
how vital is it for the latino community
and
the local latina community to
have their voice heard this year this
evening we're gathering so that we can
truly empower the latino community to
get out and vote
for the first election ever we know that
our vote
is going to win even more than it has
before but it's not going to do that if
we don't cast our ballots
so what we need to do is make sure that
every latino vote
gets counted our voices strong in this
community
and our voice is stronger when we vote
is there anything else that you want to
add about the rally tonight
voting in general anything i didn't ask
about that you think is important
this election is one of the most
important elections of our life
but it's not going to matter if we sit
up at home and sit on the sidelines and
we don't cast that ballot
so we need to make sure that our voice
is heard
we need to make sure that our nation has
leadership that we can be proud of
so this election when you cast your
ballot make sure you're casting it
in support of leadership that you can be
proud